I want you to envision
a single piece of artwork
generated by artificial intelligence.
When most of us think of AI art,
I bet we're imagining something like this.
We're all probably picturing
something totally different.
Today, with machine learning models like
DALL-E, Stable Diffusion and Midjourney,
we've seen AI produce everything
from strange life forms
to imaginary influencers
to entirely foreign,
curious kinds of imagery.
AI as a technology is fascinating to us
because we're inherently drawn
to things we cannot understand.
And with neural networks processing data
from thousands of other images
made by people from every possible
generation, every art movement,
millions of images in one simple scan,
they can produce visuals
that are so familiar
yet strikingly unfamiliar.
More poetically, AI mirrors us.
The world is beginning to change
right before our very eyes,
and it's basically divided
into two schools of thought.
There are pessimists who think AI poses
a great threat to human creativity.
And then optimists who see it
as an extension of our creativity.
So is it even possible to be truly
original as an artist anymore?
How do we begin to critically engage
with artworks made by machines?
We can start by looking at some metaphors,
narratives and insights from artists
who are truly pushing
the boundaries of AI.
Let's look to these moments
of delight, surprise,
confusion and wonder
that give us just one small glimpse
into the possibilities of encounter
with this technology.
Because as we've seen,
this is a very moral and ethical encounter
as much as an aesthetic one.
Mario Klingemann sold this piece
on auction in 2019.
It is running an AI model
trained on thousands of portraits
from the 17th to 19th centuries.
The model constantly reveals uncanny
interpretations of the human face.
Each one is unique,
generated in real time
as the machine reads its own output.
For the viewer, it's almost like peering
into the machine's hallucinations
as it conjures each new portrait.
Sofia Crespo's series "Neural Zoo"
uses neural network interpretations
of the real world
to generate unreal sea creatures
and diverse biological forms.
Frogs look like flowers.
Translucent jellyfish
have vivid internal organs.
There’s no one real creature
in these images,
but AI allows us to envision otherworldly
lifeforms in impossible detail.
This abstract piece by Sara Ludy
began as a digital painting.
It was augmented to fit a 16-by-9 ratio,
using a prompt for "torn edges"
in DALL-E 2's Outpainting.
Outpainting allows artists
to extend their creativity
beyond the frame using simple
language prompts like "torn edges."
This piece by Ivona Tau
might read as a photograph,
but it is also the work of AI.
It's the result of GAN training
on thousands of images
from the artist's personal
photo collection.
Tau curates from her own photographs,
carefully choosing the inputs
and outputs for the model.
In many ways, AI art
is a form of curation.
It becomes the process of selecting
from hundreds of images at a time.
This video pulls from models trained
on a massive data set of Tau's photos,
resulting in a kind of algorithmic memory.
But she also created a destructed
data set for the model
to symbolize forgetting
or fleeting memory.
And finally, we have Claire Silver.
Silver has called herself
a “collaborative AI artist”
in that she works intentionally
with the machine to produce her art.
Her process is constantly evolving
as the tools evolve.
She often works
with inpainting techniques,
masking and transforming
just one small piece of an image.
For this portrait, she shifted the opacity
of various sections with an Apple pencil,
transforming it bit by bit.
She likens this technique to her version
of glazing in oil painting.
Silver feeds AI-generated images
from one model into another,
effectively creating new forms
of language and understanding
for the machine itself.
Her work is half master painting,
half digital art.
Both old and new.
This piece pulls inspiration
from famed artists
like John Singer Sargent,
Evelyn De Morgan and Gustav Klimt,
almost as an homage.
Because different AI models are trained
on different sets of information,
it's almost like they're all speaking
different languages.
AI is everywhere now.
We are all now collectively
co-creating with AI,
whether we're aware of it or not.
If we want to be a part of these worlds,
we cannot design alone.
If we want to be culturally literate
in these new kinds of images
and predictions and forms,
then looking to the work of artists
is a very productive place to start.
We need to brace ourselves
for an increasingly technological future,
which is only going to multiply
all the creative possibilities
at our fingertips now.
Thank you.
(Applause)